[Applaudissements]
on à la mairie that one year on va
passer au coup de coeur jamais lancé une
machine à laver de ma vie nos noms alors
là là l'émission près voilà elle est là
tout son sens en attendait s'il vous
plaît ça intéresse ou moins intéressants
où vous n'avez jamais fait une machine à
laver et non ma flamme à la main sinon
c'est mon mari mais même les affaires
les petits sous vêtements de votre mari
vous les lavez al islam est celui là
même qui se lève on a même inscrit l on
cherche à travailler dessus
oui monsieur morini-bosc après une
journée de boulot c'est ce qu'il est
mais la machine est donc mais donc vous
avoue que réforme hier dans la
mannschaft et culottes alors là ce n'est
l'amour est bien engagé bien moi j'ai
jamais lancé de machines non plus c'est
trop lourd
un peu comme vannes et ouais même de
bons français
on éviterait ça pour la verrière mais
malheureusement
pas le choix c'est le coeur serré que je
suis obligé de lui dire tu sors